this morning US troops that president
from said were coming home from Syria
are instead moving into Iraq
defense secretary Marquez / who was in
Afghanistan this morning says the
soldiers will continue fighting Isis he
also said that some of those troops
would be left in eastern Syria to
protect oil fields from attack how
Speaker Nancy Pelosi has also been
visiting Afghanistan after a trip to
Jordan to discuss security in Syria
Holly Williams is in southern Turkey
near the Syrian border Holly what's the
latest on the US withdrawal good morning
the u.s. is now considering a plan to
keep around 200 American troops in
eastern Syria CBS News has confirmed
that's despite President Trump ordering
the controversial withdrawal of US
forces from that area earlier this month
as US troops withdraw from eastern Syria
locals threw objects at this American
convoy their departure is a betrayal
according to the Kurdish fighters who
battled with US forces against Isis they
were America's closest partners on the
ground in Syria we witnessed them
beating back the militants and laying
down their lives they came under attack
from Turkey this month after President
Trump effectively opened the door to a
Turkish offensive announcing that US
forces would pull back from the border
turkey views the Kurdish led group as a
terrorist organization it's difficult to
believe that just last month we were on
a US base in Syria where the senior
special forces commander in the campaign
against Isis described a close
relationship between American troops and
Kurdish fighters are you seeing an Isis
insurgency here we see the beginnings of
one and that's where we are we are
working very hard with our partner here
to stay after them and not allow that to
happen
now the Kurdish forces say they've
stopped fighting Isis Syrian regime
troop
have moved into parts of their territory
and 200,000 civilians have reportedly
fled the clashes with turkey vice
president Mike Pence negotiated a
ceasefire with turkish President Recep
Tayyip Erdogan last week but it runs out
tomorrow the other impact of the u.s.
withdrawal is to hand even greater
influence to Russia Turkey's president
Erdogan will meet with the Russian
President Vladimir Putin tomorrow the
future of eastern Syria could be decided
at that meeting at which the United
States will play no part Gayle all right
Holly Williams reporting from the
turkey-syria border we thank you